bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le programme de
notre édition dans les locaux de son
atelier Hamid un artiste peintre
verrierroi nous fait découvrir ses
œuvres son univers et un peu de lui
surnommé le soigneur de rue notre invité
Manu tension pense répare et réhabilite
les espaces urbains une exposition lui
est consacrée jusqu'au 24 novembre à la
Commanderie des Templiers à îencour
point de départ d'une année de résidence
vendredi 15 novembre le scarabé à La
Verrière propose une soirée et deux
invités un C plateau sous le signe de la
chanson française Nicolas Gervet a
rencontré Monsieur rou qui ouvre la
soirée chaque semaine le 7e art est m à
l'honneur dans notre chronique cinéphile
Luc Becan directeur du ciné7 àéencour
nous livre son coup de
cœur alors c'est dans les locaux de son
atelier prêté par la mairie de trappe
camide donc un artiste peintre
verrierrois nous a fait découvrir son
univers image de Patrick Jacques de
dixmud quand j'étais enfant je je
pensais qu'à ça je faisais des beaux
dessins en classe des belles peintures
et je me disais mais j'espère que plus
tard
peut-être sera mon métier court passage
à l'école des beauards beaucoup
d'ateliers dans le
14e des ateliers de sculpture de
peinture figuration le modèle vivant
pour apprendre que pour apprendre les
les ficelles
c'est c'est une alchimie la peinture il
faut connaître des secrets il faut les
découvrir passer par des épreuves aussi
ça vient en fait à partir d'une
inquiétude moi je suis inquiet
j'ai une fois que la le tableau est
réalisé c'est ça y est c'est un
soulagement une libération
quelque chose qui
apparaît partir de ex
Nilo partir de rien on arrive à
construire un univers le projet c'est
pas vraiment de faire de la figuration
justement ce serait de s'en éloigner et
en fait la figuration elle apparaî
d'elle-même des personnages on voit des
des visages on voit des regard des
yeux et tout ça
caché
le bleu en fait c'est un voyage à
DELF j'ai découvert le fameux bleu des é
de
delelf parler des des Bleus aussi du
Portugal et C
mais qume très
important une profondeur dans ce bleu et
un
rafraîchissement une quiétude
profondeur une invitation à
prier
avec aucun pinceau sinon pour quelques
finitions mais toujours avec les
doigts parfois avec les qu doigts ou les
C doigts de la main voilà
forme ça forme tout de suite quelque
chose et
rapidement ça des toiles qui des grandes
toiles des grands formats es sont sont
réalisé en peut-être quelques heures
parfois 3/4 d'heure une heure c'est très
rapide toujours des supports rigides peu
de toile très rare
aujourd'hui je pas aussi sur du verre
fixer sous ver comme faisai les
Indiens on crée un paysage CR CR visages
des portraits mais paysag le paysage
mental là c'est c'est la végétation
c'est c'est des ruisseaux qui coulent
sous les jardins
c'est couleur rouge il a un peu de sang
dans tout
ça peut-être c'est un combat
aussi la forme arrondi c'est la forme
c'est
la c'est le plafond c'est c'est le
plafond du théâtre c'est le plafond de
l'Opéra c'est le plafond de la salle
d'orchestre c'est
c'est ça c'est comme un c'est comme un
carton de un carton d'un décor en fait
un décor de de
plafond c'est une sculpture qui est
faite avec des de la poussière
d'hydrocarbure recueilli sur les les
abords de l'aireindice à trp donc les
visages son têtê es sont sont noir
sont paraî
ça c'est l'imitation parce que
effectivement
euh la sculpture elle est faite en terre
avec des
pilins la poussière mais bien sûr mais
c'est une évocation évocation peut-être
un souvenir pour demain de de C RNIS qui
qui a empoisonné les trapises pendant
tempant
d'années c'est vrai que certains usages
sont exprime un peu la peine un peu de
peine
ou peine mélancolie
peut-être des des têtes avec peut-être
cœur
gros les tableaux là qui sont ici c'est
sont destinés justement à la mairie de
traap pour la mairie de trap sera exposé
dans le haall dans toute la période de
Noël je
l'espère on continue avec les artistes
alors il arpente les villes et
intervient partout où l'espace public
présente des blessures des plaai non
refermé des structures cassées et les
réparent vous avez d'ailleurs peut-être
aperçu certaines de certains de ces
pansement rouge de cet artiste
plasticien dans le quartier notamment
des setmares à H encour bonsoir Emmanuel
Bayon bonsoir alors on vous nomme enfin
votre nom d'artiste c'est manutention
alors déjà j'ai envie de demand ce soir
je vous appelle Emmanuel ou Manu oui
enfin vous pouvez me dire Manu ok alors
Manu donc vous êtes originaire du Nord
et depuis quelques années vous réparez
donc les blessures des villes on vous
surnomme d'ailleurs le soigneur de rue
alors quel est le principe de ces
interventions oui tout à fait en fait
j'agis un peu comme un infirmier urbain
un chirurgien des rues où j'interviens
avec mes différents matériaux enfin
essentiellement le bois ouais vous
travaillez avec avec le bois c'est un
bois de d'où c'est en général du bois de
palette que je récupère les palettes
perdues donc je redonne vie à ces
matériaux morts et parce que aussi c'est
un Manu manutention mais la palette est
un des objets du
manutentionnaire ça ça colle bien aussi
pour Mau propos et ces palettes oui que
je peux trouver en fait en quantité
facilement et alors la spécificité c'est
que il y a une couleur qui vous qualifie
tout à fait il y a une couleur que
j'appose sur ce bois je pe rouge un
rouge qui est un rouge euh de référence
rale un rouge CARM référence 3002 qui
marque la ttention en fait sur les
interventions et les pansements urbains
donc c'est vraiment pour noter des des
des points de vigilance comme ça oui
tout à fait euh à la fois ça on ça
permet de remarquer la blessure la
blessure d'un sol d'un du mur euh du du
du du d'une viltre qui a volé en éclat
mais à la fois ça sécurise puis c'est le
rouge le rouge qui est porté vers
l'attention le rouge qui est le rouge de
la Croix Rouge l'infirmerie hm hm oui
donc le lien ce côté un peu secouristeou
alors il y a un côté secouriste il y a
un côté esthétique aussi l'esthétique de
l' oui il y a un choix il y a un choix
particulier en tout cas dans mes
structures c'est que en général elles
viennent de par leur couleur et de par
leur structure et la forme que je leur
donne casser le rythme en tout cas de du
mobilier h HM mais qui mais elle s'y
intègre finalement elle s'y intg je
pense aux barrières au long de l'Esco à
un moment donné à tourné où ça cassait
la linéarité des barrières via mes
structures alors justement certains
habitants cquantinois ont pu peut-être
déjà observer quelques interventions
vous avez fait notamment dans le cadre
de la Nuit Blanche qui s'est tenue en
octobre dernier alors en tant que
chirurgien urbain sur quoi vous avez
opéré par exemple dans le quartier
desoui tout à fait j'ai opéré sur une
des rampes d'escalier qui était en fait
c'est une rampe qui comprenait
normalement une grille métallique les
grill métalliqu n'était plus présente et
l'idée en fait était de sécuriser ce
trou dans la rampe d'escalier alors on
voit quelques donc en fait vous com
comment vous faites là vous arrivez vous
repérez les lieux vous prenez tout votre
matériel et vous travaillez sur place
voilà en fait donc il y a différentes
manières de procéd ici à la fois je
j'aose des choses sur place mais j'avais
quand même préparé en amont des
structures j'avais pris une série de
mesures h et à la fois aussi des fois où
je je je prends directement les
matériaux sur place que j'assemble et
qui me permet de réparer donc il y a
deux manières de procéder soit une
manière de repérage entre photographie
mesure construction et installation ou
alors le moment où j'interviens
directement
sur place donc ça nécessite parfois de
repérer les lieux en tout ou mais j'aime
beaucoup ça permet aussi de s'imprégner
des villes et de ses habitants hm hm
parce que vous arpentez les les villes
alors quel est l'objectif pour vous
concrètement là de de cette démarche
l'objectif en tout cas d'attirer l'œil
des euh des passants mais aussi des
autorités locales sur ce que je suis en
train de de faire parce que vous il vous
faut une autorisation je suppose de la
commune dans laquelle vous com Mar en
tout cas euh moi j'agis euh
sans
autorisation j'agis de manière seule de
manière sauvage en même temps mes
interventions sont elles sont tout à
fait possibles à enlever pe je les
intègre en fait je les emboite d'accord
dans les endroits à réparer où je les
fixe je les laisse avec de la corde
c'est éphémère ça peut être enlevé à
tout m tout à fait oui tout à fait
l'uvre n'est pas pérenne mais mais c'est
c'est c'est tant mieux l'important c'est
vraiment de remarquer l'endroit de lui
donner voilà un petit pansement une
petite plusvalue pendant un temps et
puis bah voilà ça questionne et là le
passant se questionne aussi sur ce que
je suis en train de faire ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il y a certaines
personnes qui mettent la main à la patte
ça m''est arrivé notamment sur Bruxelles
qui vienent vous aider o une personne a
fini de Lester une structure avec moi et
cetera et cetera et ce qu'il y a
différents moments comme ça ça ça
m'intéresse de toucher la personne
directement sur parce que moi pour moi
une petite action comme ça un petit brin
de poésie une petite touche rouge m
permet aussi de se rendre compte de ce
qui nous entoure dans nos villes et
qu'est-ce qui est possible à faire dans
les villes comment amener une plus-value
à certains lieux dans les villes donc il
a une démarche citoyenne oui c'est ça
quelque part vous poussez en fait les
les gens à se questionner sur peut-être
les dysfonctionnements de de cette
architecture cet espace urbain alors les
gens qui vous qui viennent vous voir
vous dites que certains viennent vous
voir qu'est-ce qu'il vous pose comme
question donc est-ce que je je fais
partie de la commune ça c'est une des
premières question qui arrive en général
non je ne fais pas partie de la commune
j'agis seul pourquoi ben c'est dangereux
j'y amène une sécurité mais une sécurité
passagère parce que voilà vous vous
réparez mais vous vous prévenez du du
danger aussi potentiellement un trou par
exemple un
pavé une bouche des goû euh et cetera et
cetera de quoi vous êtes le le plus fier
mais en fait il n'y a pas un travail en
particulier que que j'ai envie de
d'énoncer enfin je dirais que c'est dans
la multiplicité et en tout cas dans
l'échange qui peut y avoir d'une ville à
l'autre et puis avec les gens que là je
me sens vraiment bien et enfin le moment
où une personne tout à l'heure je disais
viens m'aider c'est des moments que
qu'on noublie pas et puis c'est moments
d'échange le moment de d'interaction h
avec une série de personnes d'accord ça
vous permet aussi de construire après
peut-être d'autres choses dans votre
imaginaire je suppose oui tout à fait
oui alors une exposition vous est
consacrée jusqu'au 24 novembre donc
c'est à la Commanderie des Templiers à
hencour alors du coup j' envie de N
demander qu'est-ce que vous présentez
puisque tout tout ce que vous faites
finalement c'est dans les rues alors
qu'est-ce qu'on peut voir dans cette
expoui voilà mon travail est in situ
donc effectivement la manière en fait de
présenter mon travail est donc c'est
présenter des photographies j'ai un
travail photographique je prends mes
photographies qui il y a des
photographies qui sont des photographies
de repérage avant installation et puis
les photographies d'après les moments où
je suis venu intervenir où je les mets
en relation mais aussi elles sont en
relation de par leurs formats aussi il y
a des formats différents il y a des il y
a des tailles et des formats différents
et ça c'est c'est là où vient le travail
du scénographe ou le travail de
l'artiste et le travail du plasticien
c'est de mettre en place aussi les
choses et les éléments puis j'ai un
travail aussi vidéo où j'ai un où j'ai
un choix d'image des moments où je suis
en train de travailler jeis en
performance hm hm et c'est ces vidéos en
fait elles ont des caractères
particuliers parce que Ben dans le
montage du film je fais des choix
j'opère des choix et puis ben je pense
qu'il faut aller voir pour s'en rendre
compte les sons ne sont pas les sons que
tout le monde pourrait entendre en
passant dans les rues il y a il y a
plein de choses qui donc c'est à voir
jusqu'au 24 novembre donc à la
Commanderie des Templiers et cet expo
marque également le point de départ
d'une année de résidence oui tout à fait
et vous allez notamment travailler avec
les scolaires alors vous allez recevoir
des classes de
de l'élémentaire jusqu'au collège en
fait c'est ça et comment ça se passe ces
ateliers qu'est-ce que vous faites avec
les enfants donc voilà euh donc les les
élèves viennent jusqu'à l'atelier qui
met qui est mon atelier en fait aussi de
résidence là où je peux travailler et
puis mon majeur propose en fait de
travailler à la fois sur l'espace
extérieur il y a différentes formes de
de travaux hein suivant les suivant les
les classes et les différents élèves
mais voilà il y a un travail qui est à
la fois donc sur tourner vers l'extériur
sur ce qui leurs entourent comment on
peut donner une plusvalue à un lieu
est-ce que c'est dans votre collège
est-ce que c'est dans votre quartier
est-ce que c'est votre arrêt de bus et
cetera et ca vous les amenez aussi à
réfléchir la place de l'artiste de l'art
contemporain aujourd'hu tout à fait tout
à fait le choix des matériaux aussi
parce queà un moment donné je leur
propose de choisir des matériaux autres
et quel matériaux on peut récupérer
quels matériaux sont utiles et faciles
d'accès comment transformer et donner
une autre vie à ses matériaux quel outil
utiliser comment peut-on détourner un
outil pour le rendre un outil qui est un
outil de création et des outils simples
donc voilà en fait c'est dans ces
différents sens que j'ai envie de de
parcourir avec eux les différents
ateliers des différents moments
d'atelier et aussi aborder la couleur la
notion de la couleur la couleur dans
dans les espaces la couleur dans nos
villes et je pense que ça c'est quelque
chose de super important je l'entends
beaucoup dans les quelques ateliers que
j'ai pu donner pour le moment ouais
quels sont les retours ouais la place de
la couleur et quelque chose d'important
je crois chez eux ils ont envie de
couleur ils ont envie de on a peut-être
des des des villes un peu trop trop
grise quoi finalement ouais tout à fait
oui donc voilà dans ces ateliers on part
on part du dessin de la
photographie la vidéo pour en faire des
structures des sculptures enfin c'est
super large je dirais qu' il y a pas un
médium particulier qu'on peut employer
c'est des ateliers qui duront donc toute
l'année toute l'année scolaire jusque
jusqu'au mois de juin oui mais écoutez
Emmanuel Manu merci merci d'être venu
sur le plateau du cosque donc votre
exposition on la retrouve jusqu'au 24
novembre donc à la Commanderie des
Templiers merci d'être venu parce qu'en
plus bah vous êtes cassé la jambe alors
juste pour voir est-ce que vous êtes
fait une béquille ou une un plâtre rouge
non mais en fait j'ai possédé un plâtre
rouge pendant une semaine mais
malheureusement après l'opération je me
suis retrouvé avec un plâtre bleu ah bon
mais j'ai fait quelques travaux avec ce
plâtre rouge c'est ça vous allez le le
réhabiliter lui aussi ouais tout à fait
ouais merci beaucoup en tout cas bon bon
retour Merci Merci à vous alors on va
continuer et nous allons retrouver sans
plus attendre Nicolas Gervet pour sa
chronique dans le
kiosque vendredi 15 novembre au scarabé
à La Verrière vous retrouverez une
soirée avec pas un mais deux invités un
coplateau musical placé sous le signe de
l'étoile de la chanson française et
Nicolas Gervet a rencontré Monsieur rou
qui ouvre la soirée on le connaît pour
petit rasta son tub à lui mais en trois
albums il n'a cessé d'évoluer avant son
concert au scarabé à La Verrière il nous
parle de son dernier album l'illégalité
joyeuse voici Monsieur rou dans le
kiosque je reviens la vie pas comme sur
un cheval pas comme un cowboy un peu
comme un
bandit échappé du bagne pour un dernier
hold il est moins engagé et puis j'ai
voulu j'ai voulu faire des textes un peu
plus introspectifs un peu plus personnel
et et voilà et assumer assumer comme
j'avais m'assumer comme j'avais envie
d'être en fait là j'ai voulu vraiment
enlever toute ironie tout second degré
j'ai pastin de propriété et jeis
Pasch les vitrin des grand magasin ça
fait pas de moi un assassin j'emprinte
juste un an ou de ce joli pullover bleu
s vaut le prix auquel tu le vend je te
le rendrai nickel dans 2
ans quand on fait de la musique on
évolue quoi donc du moins quand on en en
général les êtres humains évoluent avec
l'âge avec la vie et voilà donc après la
musique c'est juste quelque chose qui a
une photographie d'un moment j'ai pris
mon temps on a continué à faire des
concerts euh euh j'ai voyagé j'ai fait
des chanson ça voilà le l'endroit où
j'ai enregistraé l'album c'est un home
studio donc je pouvais y aller de jours
revenir une semaine après il y avait pas
vraiment de il y avait pas d'impératif
de temps donc vraiment j'ai eu envie de
moi prendre mon temps personnellement
pour aller jusqu'au bout euh des idées
que j'avais je reviens au ville un sac à
chargé pour un dernier tour de piste des
mains qui me disent allez viens des bras
en forme de
précipice je reviens à vide de ces rien
regarde un peu comme ils me remplissent
comment on est bien on m'attend comme
les filles sont belles quand elles son
TR les textes sont moins moins frontaux
c'est toujours des des thématiques moi
qui m'intéressent c'est parce que c'est
ça me touche parce que moi je suis
là-dedans personnellement c'està dire tu
tu as des idées c'est des valeurs et
puis après c'est comment tu les fais
pour les appliquer au quotidien en fait
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas de de
changer le monde mais c'est moi déjà
d'être mon plus grand travail en tout
cas seu la seule lutte que j'ai c'est
moi déjà d'être en raccord avec les
idées que je défends ça soit raccord
entre mes actes et mes idées et ça c'est
très
difficile en tout cas quand on a des
idées un peu humanistes après si on a
des des fascist ça va c'est facile quoi
parce que c'est c'est c'est le truc tout
droit c'est je te déteste parce que
c'est toi qui me fait chier je me bats
enfin la violence ça c'est facile mais
de d'avoir des idées humanistes et avoir
des actes humanistes c'est très
difficile je trouve
j'aiégalité
joyeuse l'immoralité
glasseuse je ne demande pas je me ser je
ne paye pas je prends la poire et le
dessert la crémière est son
argent je voyage beaucoup parce que
j'aime plein de musiques différentes
j'aime du rock j'aime la de la chanson
française j'aime la musique brésilienne
j'aime la musique africaine et
qu'aujourd'hui grâce à
internet je peux aller écouter un groupe
de hiph hop de Johannesbourg un groupe
de pop de de Rio de Janeiro et un groupe
de musique africaine de New York et tout
ça voilà la musique voyage et
euh et donc j'avais envie que ça voilà
c'était j'avais pas envie de me priver
j'avais envie que ça soit le reflet de
de ce que j'écoute et je reviens de tout
à vrai dire pour le meilleur et pas que
pour le pire je reviendrai de vous SD
dire ce que l'on peut mentir pour un
sourire je reviens à la
vie je reviens à vous
aussi je reviens à la
vie je reviens à vous aussi
ça donne quelque chose d'assez varié
musicalement justement et qui se prend
pas au sérieux et j'espère généreux
parce
que parce que voilà on a tous envie de
passer en tout cas nous qure les quatre
musiciens avec qui je suis sur scène on
a tous envie de passer un bon moment et
donc de de de donner de l'énergie aux
gens qui sont en face ou des des
émotions et que eux ils nous renvoient
quelque chose c'est un échange j'ai pas
vraiment de projet particulier pour le
moment à part de continuer à faire de la
musique de mélanger mélanger les genres
de le bazar et mais peut-être que
j'envisage de me présenter à la
présidentielle au élections
présidentielles
j'hésite l'illégalité
joyeuse l'immoralité
glasseuse je ne demande pas je me s je
ne paye pas je prends la poire et le
dessert la crémière est son
argent et voilà le concert c'est donc le
15 novembre scarabé à la verrière et
après monsieur rou voici madame brune
Aurélia oui je sais
inspiration un petit manque
d'inspiration ce soir Nico mais tant que
je ne compte pas pour des prunes alors à
la semaine prochaine passons tout de
suite à notre chronique
céphile nous sommes mercredi c'est donc
l'heure des sorties ciné au micro
d'éodim moine un très
belle prestation une belle histoire de
marin vraiment très très chouette avec
une belle histoire en plus qui se
raccordne avec les problématiques de
l'immigration c'est simplement génial
quoi ça rappelle bien le V des
globes le les les voocation
de rechercheur soi-même retour sur
soi-même introspection j'ai bien aimé
j'ai trouvé que les images de mer
étaient magnifiques j'ai beaucoup aimé
ce film parce qu'elle n'est pas
uniquement un documentaire sur la mer et
sur le vent des globes pas mal pour un
premier film ça pose les bonnes bases
les acteurs sont bons ça fait plaisir de
revoir à for dans un film et le film est
complet très bien moi ça m'a vraiment
plu au niveau des effets spéciaux bien
réalisés l'histoire se tient c'est très
sympa non non un très bon fil j'ai passé
un bon moment je l'ai trouvé très bien
Thierry l'ermite était était génial en
fait c'est c'est un de ses un de ses
meilleurs rôles et Raphaël personnas
aussi qui qui est excellent Mo j'ai
beaucoup
aimé la chronique cinéphile c'est aussi
l'occasion d'entendre un professionnel
nous parler du cinéma et de son coup de
cœur de la semaine cette semaine
justement c'est au tour de Luc bean
directeur du ciné7 à ilencour bon alors
mon coup de cœur de la semaine enfin
c'est un semi- coup de cœur enfin c'est
quand même un coup de cœur un peu nuancé
c'est gravity d'Alfonso quaron alors
effectivement donc c'est le film dont
tout le monde parle en ce moment que
tout le monde va voir je l'ai vu hier
donc il faut effectivement le voir il
faut le voir en 3D j'insiste parce que
je pense que c'est vraiment un film qui
a été fait pour la 3D c'est extrêmement
impressionnant visuellement
techniquement c'est parfait il y a rien
à dire c'est une expérience de pure
cinéma on vit vraiment des moments assez
incroyable on est complètement pris dans
le film par contre la petite réserve que
je fais mais je crois que je suis pas le
seul à la faire c'est le scénario qui
est quand même un petit peu léger je
pense qu'on peut difficilement comparer
gravity à 200 le LCÉE de l'espace enfin
allez-y quand même parce que c'est
quelque chose que un film que vous
n'oublierez pas quand même parce que
visuellement encore une fois et
techniquement c'est absolument parfait
et très beau à
voir
il y a
quelqu'un et pour finir je vous propose
quelques idées de sortiese ces prochains
jours alors déjà si vous avez envie de
musique Axel ber se donne en concert
demain soir donc c'est à 20h30 à la
batterie à Guill encour et si vous avez
plutôt envie de rire et de vous amuser
en famille je vous propose un spectacle
les encombrants font leur cirque c'est
samedi à 20h30 à la merurise attrape des
6 ans voilà notre édition est à présent
terminée merci de nous avoir suivi sur
TVFI je vous retrouve donc la semaine
prochaine en direct à 18h30 mercredi
d'ici là profitez donc de la richesse de
notre territoire et de tous les lieux à
visiter à
mercredi